[Música]
pocas personas han influido en
pensadores actuales y en el mundo como
Platón
un filósofo del siglo XX llegó incluso a
describir a la filosofía occidental como
notas al pie a la obra de Platón
Platón creó la primera universidad
occidental y fue profesor de las Mentes
más grandes de la antigua Grecia pero
Incluso como uno de los fundadores de la
filosofía no era perfecto junto con sus
Grandes Ideas Platón tuvo algunas que no
resistieron El paso del tiempo
Este es un breve recorrido por algunas
de sus mejores y peores ideas Platón
sostuvo que más allá de nuestro mundo
imperfecto estaba el Mundo inmutable
perfecto de las formas
las formas son versiones ideales de
cosas y conceptos que vemos a nuestro
alrededor
sirven como una especie de manual de
instrucciones para nuestro propio mundo
flotando en el mundo de las formas está
el árbol ideal y el canal ideal de
YouTube e incluso la justicia ideal o el
amor ideal
nuestra propia realidad está compuesta
por copias imperfectas de formas ideales
Platón sostenía que los filósofos debían
esforzarse por contemplar y comprender
esas formas perfectas para navegar mejor
por nuestra realidad engañosa si bien
puede parecer una tontería la
desconexión entre el mundo como aparece
y la mayor verdad subyacente es uno de
los problemas más acuciantes de la
filosofía ha sido objeto de miles de
páginas por parte de teólogos filósofos
y guionistas por igual
[Música]
se plantea preguntas como si debemos
confiar en que los sentidos lleguen a la
verdad o en nuestra propia razón para
Platón La respuesta es la razón es la
única que nos da al menos el potencial
para contemplar las formas Pero la razón
no siempre permea para el propio Platón
cuando trató de situar a la humanidad
entre los animales nos agrupó con las
aves
bípedo sin plumas fue su designación
oficial
diógenes El cínico molestó Por esta
definición irrumpió en la clase de
Platón con un pollo desplumado
anunciando he aquí al hombre de Platón
pero volvamos a algunas buenas ideas
Platón es uno de los primeros teóricos
de la política en la historia y con
Aristóteles se ve como uno de los
fundadores de la ciencia política
concluyó que gobernar no era diferente
de cualquier otro oficio como alfarero o
médico y que solo quienes dominaran el
oficio podrían liderar
gobernar era el arte de contemplar las
formas en su República Platón imaginó
una utopía donde la justicia es el
objetivo final la ciudad ideal de Platón
buscaba un equilibrio armonioso entre
sus partes y debía ser liderada por un
rey filósofo
milenios antes de su momento Platón
también razonó que las mujeres podían
gobernar en esta ciudad modelo
por desgracia Platón era inconsistente
con las mujeres y las comparaba con los
niños también creía que el útero de la
mujer era un animal vivo que podría
deambular por su cuerpo y causar
enfermedades esta mala idea también
expuesta por otros contemporáneos de
Platón influyó tristemente durante
cientos de años en la medicina europea
Por otra parte pensó que la sociedad
debía dividirse en tres grupos
productores militares y gobernantes que
una gran mentira noble debía convencer a
todos de seguir esta estructura
la mentira noble que propuso era que
todos nacemos con el oro la plata o una
mezcla de metal y hierro en nuestras
almas que determinan nuestros roles en
la vida
algunos pensadores han dado crédito a la
idea de la mentira noble como prototipo
de la propaganda del siglo XX y el rey
filósofo como fuente de inspiración para
los dictadores que las usaban unas ideas
malas no deberían empañar el estatus de
Platón como uno de los más grandes
filósofos de la historia Platón dio a
los líderes y pensadores que vinieron
después un Punto de partida a través de
los siglos pudimos probar esas ideas
mediante la escritura y la experiencia y
aceptamos algunas y rechazamos otras
seguimos refinando modificando y
editando sus ideas que se han vuelto
pilares del mundo moderno
para continuar explorando filosofías
antiguas que nos ayudan a abordar
preguntas modernas consulte estos videos
[Música]